all right in Asia this morning China's
leader Xi Jinping is beginning an
historic third term in office after
being anointed again as the head of the
country's Communist party but there was
an unexpected twist in the normally
highly choreographed Chinese National
Congress over the weekend when his
predecessor was escorted off the stage
Elizabeth Palmer shows us what this
means for the rest of the world
just as everyone expected Xi Jinping was
confirmed as the head of Chinese
Communist Party
and will now begin an unprecedented
third term as the country's leader his
six top lieutenants all men are also all
Xi Jinping loyalists evidence that he
has now amassed more power than any
Chinese leader since Mao Zedong
the new leadership lineup didn't impress
Asian stock markets Hong Kong's
influential Hang Seng Index fell more
than six percent and it didn't help that
there is no sign she is zero coveted
policy which has put the brakes on
economic growth will end anytime soon
in the closing chapters of the party
Congress there was one Awkward
unscripted Moment two AIDS apparently
removed she's predecessor 79 year old
hujin Tao from the front row of
dignitaries
was he unwell or was it a political
Purge we'll probably never know as the
incident has already been scrubbed from
Chinese TV and social media
for CBS mornings I'm Elizabeth Palmer in
Tokyo
quite an image there Liz farmer force in
Tokyo Liz thank you very much